Alright, you're done.
Let's start by uncommenting out that text.
As you can see, you need
that forecast string
to pass on to our DetailActivity.
So what do we use
to get that forecast string?
Well we're lucky here,
because we actually
get the adapterView passed in.
All we have to do is cast at
a SimpleCursorAdapter
and then we can get the cursor.
We can move it to our position,
then we can use string.format,
to get a formatted string
based upon the values
of our columns.
Note once again, the nice use
of our column indices.
One ending curly brace ( } ),
and let's move that intent stuff
inside of there.
And that's it.
Now we'll be able to click on it again
and it'll actually go
to our normal DetailView.
Let's try it out.
So here we are,
there's our list View,
we can go right into details.
Pretty cool.
However, if we change
our temperature units
to imperial here,
it doesn't actually update.
It would be nice if that View
was based on the same kind
of cursor model we have here.
Something that was observing
with the content observer,
and would actually update,
when we changed our setting.